only three months since Archie arrived
it seems Prince Harry is already
thinking about a bigger family and not
just what it would mean for them but the
impact it could have on the planet in a
conversation with environmentalist dr.
Jane Goodall in Vogue magazine they
talked about their fears for the natural
world and Harry's desire to have more
children
when dr. jane says not too many harry
replies to maximum that i've always
thought this place is borrowed we need
to be focusing on exactly what we can do
immediately now and that's changing how
we live not how many of us there are
live pepino has decided not to have
children she set up the group birth
strike to bring together those who've
made the same decision for the sake of
the environment I made the decision to
not have biological children so I could
put my time and energy into activism and
then I found out that lots of other
people are struggling with this decision
as well and that seemed like a powerful
way to raise consciousness about what's
happening because if there isn't a
future then people aren't going to feel
safe to have children so how much does
having a child impact the environment
well just one child is equal to about 60
tons of co2 equivalent a year to put
that in context driving a car generates
2.4 tons a year and a transatlantic
flight generates 1.6 tons of co2
equivalents from the Queen to the
Cambridge's the Royals aren't known for
having small families and this year
their carbon emissions have also gone up
mainly from flying around the world on
behalf of the government leading some to
suggest that Harry is preaching too much
considering he travels all over the
world he's constantly flying to Africa
and they say that you know it is very
hypocritical we've decided to stop it
too and I think it does sort of factor
in the back of my mind that yeah we're
replacing ourselves we're not adding to
the existing sort of population crisis
as long as you can look after them you
can take care of all your working yeah I
think you should do what you want to do
this is the first time the prospect of
another royal baby has caused a debate
around climate change as
subject that will always be close to
Prince Harry's heart Rhiannon Mills Sky
News